A visit to Denmark is a journey.
So why not make the most of it and use the journey to the congress...
...to show some different aspects of Denmark?
We have an excellent modern infrastructure with efficient public transport...
...and distances are short.
They could get an understanding of our way of life,...
...rub shoulders with the natives...
...and maybe even do a little sightseeing en route.
We could show them examples...
...of the cutting-edge technology Denmark excels in...
...like our robot and welfare technology...
...and green tech solutions such as our offshore windmills and solar panels.
And finally, you can use Lego in your meetings...
...to help encourage great new ways of thinking.